I genuinely believe like okay the
relationship ends this is where it ends
we're done now
I I am making a choice as to how I will
remember you and and we do it in
relationships like I I always tell
people you know if you ever want to see
a couple light up if they're ever like
the couple at the table that's you know
it seems like they got in a fight or
something ask them how they met
and most people when they talk about how
they met like their face softens they
both in the other person looking at them
telling the story gets that look you
were talking about before and because
they remember that thing and how they
felt at that moment and when when this
person was a choice
not a default not their automatic plus
one but the person they asked to the
wedding not though of course you're
bringing her it's your wife you bring
your wife places like it was
still hey there's like you know three
and a half billion women and I'm picking
you you know like that that feeling and
and I don't know when why when a
relationship ends
you can't do that a lesson I learned
when my mother passed away of a very
two-year terrible battle with cancer and
was on hospice and was very very sick
and it was a very slow and awful end
and I remember one of my worst fears was
that this is how I would remember my
mother for the rest of my life that I
would never be able to think of her that
I didn't think of what she had become in
the last months where she was withered
away to nothing in this bed you know
and I learned over time that memory is
very kind that like that faded somehow
and that now like when I remember her I
remember her healthy and vibrant I
remember her laughter I remember
positive things some of that is I like
to look at photos of that or but some of
it is just how I think memory works and
I I don't know why we don't apply that
to relationships and I think part of it
is because we have this binary view of
relationships that it's either success
which means you live happily ever after
for the rest of your lives and die
together
or like in short succession
or it was wrong it was awful and I I
don't understand why that would have to
be how we do it I think we could look at
relationships like what they are which
is Chapters
in a book
and that book is our life
and those chapters all have significance
and none of them would have the later
chapters none of them would happen
without the prior ones so there's this
beauty in me of that and it's I don't
know if that it's a choice
or if that is how it is and the rest is
just narrative that we've put on top of
it culturally for some reason well I
think to push back a little bit I think
memory
can also I think it is a deliberate
choice because I think memory can
basically that's how trauma works it can
Surface the negative stuff and the
negative stuff completely drowns out all
the positives so it's I think
uh uh it's a deliberate choice to make
your memory probably work that way you
know in relationships betrayal can do
that right sort of uh cheating
infidelity
like one event can almost erase the
entirety of your
uh understanding of the past and all the
memories are sort of shrouded in this
darkness of okay what I believed was
true is totally untrue and started to
overcome that and still appreciate the
Beautiful Moments I'm
continually astounded
by how
long
the hurt and anger of betrayal can
reverberate
I I have clients who were four years
five years past
when the divorce ended the cheating was
discovered and there is angry as they
were the day they found out
and and I I don't know what that's about
oh yeah because I also have clients that
they like look back on it and they go
you know
we screwed up like we were you know we
didn't do the best but we did the best
we could do at the time and you know we
like there should be stars for Wars like
ours you know that should be champagne
for the survival yeah that's beautiful
like we made it through you know like we
survived it and we were fools and we
were fools for love and there are worse
things in the world to be fools for it
but I I also do think that most
relationships where there was infidelity
and it's not a it's not a popular thing
to say and I'll get i'll get pilloried
for it but great you know
I just don't
know and I don't want to blame the
victim of infidelity
but was the relationship really where it
needed to be like had were you truly the
most just dutiful spouse who was seeing
this person's needs be met again we've
established in the granola story that
people can sometimes with good
intentions not be meeting their
partner's needs or perceiving their
partner's needs or their partner isn't
communicating them the right way or all
of the above
but I I I've rarely seen very happy
content couples that cheat on each other
and so I I understand there's a shame in
saying this person cheated on me or I
cheated on this person
because I represent you know I represent
I represent the cheater and I represent
the cheated I represent the victim of
domestic violence I represent the
perpetrator of domestic violence I
represent the person with the substance
use disorder the person married to the
person so I I don't get to choose the
white or the black hat like I have my
client and that's my client
and and it forces me to put myself into
their story from their point of view
and I think that kind of radical empathy
that you need to engage in on a daily
basis to represent people in those kinds
of proceedings
it just I don't know it's it it just
doesn't seem like there's good guys and
bad guys you know it just seems like
it's complicated
and people's intentions and where they
actually end up are different